[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité nous débuterons ce
journal avec la mise en œuvre des
nouvelles mesures de sécurité dans les
établissements scolaires demandé par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale à la
suite de l'assassinat de Dominique
Bernard notre partenaire TL7 s'est rendu
dans un lycée de Saint-Étienne dans la
Loire pour le constater
elle est l'une des 17 dernièes Esap
français des camps de concentration naz
en cette période douloureuse en raison
du conflit
israélo-palestinien le témoignage de
Ginette cololinka devant les élèves d'un
lycée d'Épinal prend un sens tout
particulier une équipe de vuge
télévision a recueilli son témoignage
vous verrez et puis nous consacrerons
une page de ce journal aux conséquen du
changement climatique en Corse le crabe
bleu et la hantise des pêcheurs avec ses
grosses pinces bleues ce crabe venu
d'Amérique du Nord coupe leur filet et
dévore tout un impact économique et
écologique sans précédent comme l'a
constaté une équipe de télépaisé sur
place enfin notre partenaire Canal 32
nous emmènera à suivre l'entraînement de
ce chien d'origine canadienne le
Terreneuve qui bien au-delà de sa
gentillesse pourrait épauler les maîtres
nageurs sauvteurs cet été sur les bords
des plages une association milite pour
obtenir qu'il soit reconnu d'utilité
publique 15 jours après l'assassinat de
Dominique Bernard dans son collège à
haras un sondage ELAB indique que 84 %
des Français sont inquiets face à la
menace terroriste géralde d'armanana
ministre de l'Intérieur a demandé un
renforcement significatif de la sécurité
dans les établissements scolaires pour
notre partenaire TL7 dans la Loire
marie-liis Pario s'est rendu dans un
lycée de Saint-Étienne qui dispose déjà
de portiques électroniques et de caméras
de surveillance aux
entrées ce geste est simple et pourtant
il permet la sécurité des 500 élèves du
lycée jeanmonet oui ça me rassure
d'avoir l' parque quoi je me dis qu'il y
a pas n'importe qui qui peut entrer et
aussi d'avoir la police devant le lycée
ben ça rassure l'annonce de l'attaque au
couteau à haras et le décès du
professeur Dominique Bernard a eu
l'effet d'une honte de choc dans
l'établissement ça m'a choqué parce que
c'est des élèves qui ont fait ça et
l'école c'est quelque chose là où on est
censé se sentir en sécurité donc ça m'a
choqué qu'il ait pu avoir ça ici depuis
les mesures de sécurité ont été durci le
sac des élèves doit être fouillé mais
elle concerne surtout les personnes
extérieures à l'établissement elles
doivent par exemple justifier leur
identité devant certains lycées on
retrouve des bornes antioiture bélier
des alarmes anti-intrusion des vidéo
protection des portiques de sécurité les
établissements sont comparés à de
véritables forteresses il me semble
qu'on est à un niveau de sécurité qui
est qui est important après ça reste un
établissement scolaire euh donc ce n'est
ni un bunker ni une prison c'est un un
juste équilibre entre nos missions
d'éducation et la la garantie de
sécurité que l'on doit aux enfants et
aux adultes de l'établissement depuis
2016 la région a investi 110 millions
d'euros pour la sécurité des
établissements scolaires sous leur
délégation tous les lycées ont au moins
des portiques à leur
entrée c'est l'une des 17 dernières
ESCAP des camps de concentration nazi la
française Ginette colinka témoignait
devant les élèves d'un lycée d'Épinal
elle a délivré un message de paix alors
que le conflit entre Israël et la
Palestine est à son paroxisme elle
rappelle l'horreur qu'elle a vécu à
Auschwitz durant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale une rencontre chargée d'émotion
à laquelle a assisté notre partenaire
vuche télévision
elle était de passage à épin avant les
événements qui touchent actuellement le
territoire
israélo-palestinien rencontre intense
d'émotion avec Ginette cololinka l'une
des 17 derniers survivants de la
déportation durant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale en France le 13 mars 1944 la
jeune fille issue d'une famille juive
non pratiquante se faire rafler par la
guestapo elle est emmenée à hwiitz
Birkenau en Pologne dans un camp de
concentration à l'arrivée son père son
frère son neveu sont immédiatement gazés
dans le camp d'extermination à tenant
jugé apte à travailler on lui tatoue sur
le bras un nombre
78599 le début d'une descente en enfer
on nous a réduit dans un
état
lamentable vous êtes plus rien ils vous
ont tout enlevé qui pouvait faire
quelque chose qui vous différenciait les
uns des autres on vous a min nu on vous
a enlevé vos poils on vous a levé vos
cheveux on vous a habillz d'une façon
très ridicule et on est tous aussi
ridicule les unes que les autres on nous
frappait on nous nourrissait pas on
avait des travaux vraiment très très
très durs à faire longtemps incapable de
témoigner Ginette colinka a décidé
depuis 20 ans d'aller à la rencontre de
la jeunesse sa crainte le négationnisme
à 98 ans elle démarre comme cela son
propos tout ce que vous pourrez
apprendre dans les livres ce n'est pas
vrai c'était pire quand je dis on était
battu l'image que j'ai c'est le B qui
tap la victime elle est par terre à ses
pied ensanglanté et vous avez le bourau
qui continue à la frapper jusqu'à ce
qu'elle soit
évanouie ou morte j'en avais déjà
entendu parler mais on l'imagine pas
aussi difficile que comme elle le
raconte ici en vrai en face de nous
cétait assez touchant que quelqu'un a le
courage de raconter ça 1200 membres de
la communauté juive sont arrêtés dans
les vuges 80 % d'entre eux ne
reviendront pas voilà et puis en bref la
campagne de vaccination contre la grippe
saisonnière qui touche chaque année
entre 2 et 6 millions de personnes à
débuter ce geste n'est plus réservé au
médecin Sébastien Germain pour notre
partenaire Montblanc l'a constaté dans
cette officine de chambéie de plus en
plus de Français n'hésite plus à aller
en pharmacie pour se faire vacciner
chaque année je prends mon rendez-vous
je fais ça dès le premier jour même
éventuellement ouis ou oui je suis à
fond là-dedans oui oui je pense qu'on a
plus de chance de de de on a moins de de
problèmes en se faisant vacciner qu'en
attrapant la grippe voilà les restos du
cœur du valdoise se préparent à un hiver
difficile la grippe arrive le froid
s'installera bientôt et c'est le moment
général où les restos du cœur ont les
plus fortes demande dans le valdoise
l'association créée par Coluche a
distribué 35 % de repas supplémentaires
ces derniers mois une explosion de la
demande qui se cumule avec une forte
inflation des produits alimentaires que
doit acheter l'association les resto
pourraient être obligés de restreindre
ses prestations pour la campagne d'hiver
qui démarrera le 20 novembre notre
partenaire vootv a rencontré son
directeur qui ne cache pas son
inquiétude
écoutterz chaque année les restos du
cœur du valdoise distribue un peu plus
de 2 millions de repas tout est stocké
ici dans cet entrepôt de 4500 m² à
Argenteuil on trouve ici dans l'entrepôt
tous les produits alimentaires bien sûr
à la fois ambiant et frais des produits
bébés ilalement que faut pas que je les
oublie c'est très très important les
produit bébé c'est très cher pour les
familles et cette année les restos se
préparent à une campagne d'ivers
compliquée nous avons distribué sur la
campagne d'été en terme de repas
distribué 35 % supérieur à l'année
passée ce qui est énorme ça représente
plus de 400000 repas en plus de ce qu'on
a connu l'an dernier donc c'est colossal
les restos reçoivent beaucoup de dons
mais 30 % de l'aide alimentaire est en
fait acheté par
l'association alors avec l'inflation la
facture est salée les achats eux aussi
sont frappés par l'inflation et
l'alimentaire des restos on est plus
proche des 20 %. donc ces repas en plus
on doit les acheter il en a beaucoup
plus à acheter et beaucoup plus cher
avec des Finances à la baisse les resto
risquent de devoir restreindre leur
prestations ça veut dire effectivement
donner un peu moins à chacun et
également certaines personnes qui
étaient un peu
limite ENF je veux dire les moins
démunis des plus démunis si je puis dire
eu et ben on on risque de ne pas pouvoir
les accepter malheureusement évidemment
ça nous font le cœur c'est c'est
dramatique mais mais malheureusement les
cont financières sont là face aux
difficultés des Restos du cœur le
Conseil départemental du valdoise a
décidé d'augmenter de 50 % son soutien à
l'association avec une aide de 37500 €.
le département a également renforcé son
soutien aux 14 épiceries sociales du
valdoise voilà ouvrons maintenant notre
page dédiée au changement climatique à
ces conséquences et aux innovations
aussi qui en découlent en quelques
années les eaux de la Corse et plus
largement de la mer Méditerranée ont été
colonisé par le crabe bleu ce crustacé
venu d'Amérique est un fléo pour les
autres espèces marines et pour les
pêcheurs de l'île un problème pris très
au sérieux par les scientifiques un
reportage d'Angel richickchardi pour
télépaiser sur
place les premières lueurs du matin
inondent les temps de bigouia l'une des
SEP réserves naturelles de l'île mais
sous les EAU tranquilles vit un crabe
bleu qui mange tous les poissons et
détruit les filets et des pêcheurs
d'habitude ce sont six embarcations qui
sillonnent les temps aujourd'hui Michel
est tout seul ce crab qui vient
d'Amérique du Nord peut parcourir
jusqu'à 15 km par jour et il n'a aucun
prédateur alors les dégâts sont très
nombreux c'est du matériel comm qui est
pas qui est pas fait pour les crabes
pour le moment on a pas trouvé de
solution à part voilà de de les sortir
de l'eau
et si on arrivait à la limite all les
aller commercialiser ça serait déjà
quelque chose de gagner mais là on n pas
de marché pour le moment on n' pas de
marché pour aider les pêcheurs l'office
de l'environnement de la Corse a dû
investir 22000 € dans des filets plus
résistants mais aussi des puces
électroniques ont été installées sur
plusieurs crabes pour surveiller les
populations et mieux les contrôler c'est
une espèce qui s'est manifestement très
bien adaptée qui serait potentiellement
aussi favorisé par le changement
climatique et donc qui pose après
souciis une fois qu' qu'elle est
implantée évidemment sur sur l'ensemble
de écosystème un plan de lutte régionale
est prévu dans les semaines à venir pour
inciter les restaurateurs à préparer du
crab bleu Sacher est déjà très prisé en
Asie pourvu qu'il en soit de même sur
l'île nous le savons la crise de
l'énergie ne se règlera pas sans un
changement radical de méthode de
production lancé en 2021 à Grenoble une
start-up tente de générer de
l'électricité grâce à des cervolants
l'entreprise est encore en phase de
recherche et de développement mais l' I
est grande commercialiser des éoliennes
mobiles de 25 m de long d'ici 2028 c'est
un reportage de Miki pour téléGrenoble
regardez permettra tous d'avoir une
indépendance énergétique grâce à un
colant voilà l'idée de Garret Smith en
lançant son entreprise en 2021 je pense
qu'on va pouvoir voler pour de
l'autoconsommation pour un usage
industriel le cerolant éolien pourrait
fournir 100 kW une énergie suffisante
pour alimenter tout un village
100 kW ça ça va fournir pour une
centaine de maisons par exemple les
villages au Canada ou village en Afrique
aujourd'hui ils ont ils sont dépendants
des groupes électrogènes diesel et pour
arriver à notre objectif de zé émission
net en 2050 on a besoin de de promouvoir
des technologies comme le nôtre
l'énergie est produite par le vent qui
force sur les câbles du cvolant relié à
un générateur au sol le coût de
production serait trois fois moins élevé
qu'une éolienne classique
on a prouvé qu'on peut faire voler un
cylindre qu'on entraîne à partir du sol
donc il y a rien il y a pas de moteur
qui sont embarqués donc juste avec
l'effet Magnus avec le vent on arrive à
faire voler notre cervolant le plus gros
avantage aussi c'est que nous on peut
déployer notre système et après le
récupérer si on on en a plus besoin on a
moins de résistance sociétale moins de
de crainte parce que le système il se
pose au sol sur son socle quand il y a
pas de vent et ça fait aucun pollution
visuelle sur le paysage aujourd'hui la
mission est de confirmer la performance
et la stabilité en vol mais les essais
ne se passent pas toujours comme prévu
les prototypes sont mis à rue d'épreuve
il y a occasionnellement un petit bug
avec le l'allumage des moteurs les
contrôleurs moteurs font tourner
immédiatement les moteurs sans qu'on le
commande et malheureusement j'étais pas
prêt et c'est un petit alla du des essa
en vol il faut célébrer chaque échec par
c'est une apprentissage c'est réparé
ou pour le moment le prototype est petit
et ne génère qu'un kilow l'entreprise a
besoin d'un fond de 5 à 10 millions
d'euros pour lancer le modèle de 25 m de
long pour une commercialisation horizon
2028 et puis plus au sud dans camarg si
le changement climatique perturbe de
nombreux cycles de production il existe
une production céréalière qui se porte
bien c'est celle du riz et
particulièrement en camarque d'ailleurs
une année parfaite pour faire pousser du
riz avec de l'eau pour ses pieds du
soleil pour sa tête et suffisamment de
vent pour le sécher un riz approvisionné
par le Rône et soufflé par le mistral
des caractéristiques on ne peut plus
camargaise qui lui permettent de
disposer d'une indication géographique
protégée via ocitanie Antoine Guillet
nous emmène dans les risières de la
famille
benoî il dessine les paysages de la
Camargue et les terres de la famille
Benoît
Mathieu Saffire dans les risières pour
moissonner malgré une météo peu
favorable les parcelles sont sèches
parce qu'il a pas PL mais on a pas des
très bonnes conditions climatiques dans
le sens que tous les matins il y a du
brouillard et de l'humidité du coup on
peut pas attaquer bonheur le matin et le
soir le soir de bonheur on est aussi
arrêté donc après elle se passe bien la
journée ça va mais le soir et le matin
il y a trop d'humide on peut pas peut
pas
récolter une récolte pas simple mais une
année année 2023 parfaite pour faire
pousser du riz avec de l'eau pour ses
pieds du soleil pour sa tête et
suffisamment de vent pour le sécher un
riz approvisionné par le rô et soufflé
par le mistral des caractéristiques on
ne peut plus qu'à margise qui lui
permettent d'avoir une indication
géographique protégée un bel argument de
vente pour Claris la cousine de Mathieu
la particularité du ramar comparé aux
autres riz déjà comme on peut le voir
ils sont un peu plus ils sont moins
longs et fins que les riz asiatiques
mais ils sont un peu plus j'aime bien
dire jouflu quoi ils sont un peu plus
costaud un peu plus un peu plus ronds la
famille Benoît espère commercialisé
comme chaque année environ 1200 tonnes
de riz un cru 2023 récolté pendant
encore une dizaine de jours mais il
faudra attendre 2024 pour le
déguster nous nous les trouvons
attachantes mais lorsque leur rendement
baisse les poules pondeuse finissent en
général tristement à l'abattoir
l'association pooule pour tous les
rcupère auprès d'éleveur afin de les
mettre en vente auprès de particuli
toutes ces poules proviennent d'élevage
bio de plein air ou de la belle avec
plus de 160 relé en toute la France LMTV
Sart a rencontré Alicia salarié de
l'association heureuse d'offrir une
nouvelle vie à ses galinesac
regardez bientôt une nouvelle vie attend
ses poules pondeuses après un an et demi
d'élevage elles sont mises en vente par
poule pour tous une association qui
récupère ses galinacés auprès d'éleveurs
pour leur éviter l'abatto
un peu honteux quand même de mettre des
poules à l'abattoir alors qu'elles ont
18 mois et sont complètement encore cap
de pondre mais parce qu'on estime que
c'est plus assez rentable chaque année
c'est près de 50 millions de poules
pondeuses qui sont élevé en France des
poules de 18 mois considéré comme plus
rentable pour certains éleveurs mais qui
peuvent pondre encore quelques années P
encore 4 ans après sur le temps de vie
ça joue un petit peu mais ça varie la
réservation se déroule en ligne sur le
site de P pour tous et selon la région
des dates de permanence et un point de
distribution y sont indiqués et
certaines de ces poules ne manquent pas
de saisir l'opportunité quand elles se
présente de nouvelles opérations de
vente auront lieu prochainement dans la
région Pays de la Loire y compris en
Sart rendez-vous sur le site internet de
l'association pour réserver votre poule
pondeuse bonne journée à vous au revoir
apporter une bouée de sauvetage épauler
un sauveteur ou tirer une embarcation de
plusieurs tonnes ce sont les missions de
sauvetage en mer que peut mener le
terneuve car rien ne fait peur à cette
race de chiens qui trouve ses origines
au Canada récemment h chiens et leurs
maîtres ont multiplié les exercices sur
les berges d'un lac de l'Aube afin que
ce chien secouriste soit reconnu
d'utilité publique car la plupart des
plages et littoraux lui sont interdits
l'été en France notre partenaire Canal
32 n'a pas hésité à se jeter à l'eau
avec lui
regardez ce dimanche matin sur la plage
de dville pas de nageurs en vue mais des
chiens qui n'ont pas peur de se jeter à
l'eau 8 neu enchaînent les exercices
sous les yeux etbis des touristes et de
leur maîtrre onend aller chercher un
objet une bouée n'importe quoi et après
on va comme cet après-midi je vais
commencer à y apprendre à apporter un
objet à une personne là c'est un peu
plus
compliqué apporter ou rapporter une
ligne de vie une bouée de sauvetage
épauler un suteur et tirer une embarque
de plusieurs tonnes pas de quoi effrayer
le terneuve 70 kg de muscle un
souous-poil imperméable des pattes
larges la race trouve ses origines au
Canada d'abord amis fidèle des pêcheurs
elle excè aujourd'hui dans les
sauvetages en mer c'est très bien pour
les maîtres nageurs et c'est très bien
pour regarder les enfants
instinctivement en fait les TER neuves
regardent les enfants oou les gens s'il
se noi ils vont essayer de les sauver et
en fait c'est un chien qui a beaucoup de
caractère des qualités innées et un
instinct qui qui ont séduit Vanessa et
les membres du club champonnois de
chiens de sauvetage nautique une journée
d'exercice pour le plaisir de voir leurs
chiens en pleine nature mais attention
pour l'instant il n'est pas question
d'intervenir officiellement nous on a un
club on va dire qui on nintervient pas
sur des lieux pour faire de la du
sauvetage à proprement dit parce que
pour être sauveteur avec internu il faut
être sauveteur nautique c'est une
passion et puis on le fait sérieusement
parce que bah on peut des fois être
amené quand même à à Inter venir on se
balade avec notre Terre Neuve et puis on
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
est en train de se noyer ou qui est en
difficulté bah ça nous permet
d'intervenir quand même si le terneu
aime l'eau la plupart des plages et
littoraux touristiques lui sont interdit
l'été en France l'association milite
pour que plus d'espace lui soit
aménagé voilà et puis durant ces
vacances si vous séjournez dans le
bordelai je ne peux que vous recommander
d'embarquer à bord de la fusée
d'objectif lune de plonger au fond de la
mer à la recherche du trésor de RAC
camel rouge c'est en tout cas ce que
propose le parcours expo immersive
Tintin qui a pris ses quartiers au
bassin des lumières un magnifique lieu
de Bordeaux un voyage à 360° qui ravira
les tintinophiles avérés ou les amateurs
de ce nouveau genre d'exposition notre
partenaire TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest n'a pas résisté à la tentation
regardez pour la première fois le 9ar
s'invite au bassin des lumières mais pas
avec n'importe quel personnage c'est
Tintin qui vient faire le chaud le fruit
de 8 mois de
préparation forcément HERG étant le
peut-être le dessinateur de bande
dessiné le plus célèbre le plus renommé
du 20e siècle il fallait lui rendre
hommage au bassin des lumières et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi de
d'accueillir cette très belle
[Musique]
exposition une exposition qui a déjà été
montrée à Paris au beauau deProvence à
Bruxelles et à Lausanne mais qui prend
une teinte particulière à la base
sous-marine on retrouve forcément le le
fameux baptis CAF qui a été
construit par le professeur Tournesol
qui est un sous-marin en forme de requin
et qui s'insère parfaitement dans la
base sous-marine le parcours a été
construit avec la société chargée de
l'exploitation commerciale de l'œuvre
d'Erg un patrimoine inemporel les
histoires qu'il
racontent vous pouvez les interpréter de
manière différente vous pouvez les lire
de manière différente en fonction de
l'âge que vous avez en lisant
vous faites un un voyage dans l'histoire
du 20e siècle c'est un siècle qui vient
juste de de finir et c'est quand même un
siècle qui est très important et et RG
en plus avec cette ce génie de de
l'universalité et du message universel
en fait Tintin l'aventure immersive est
à voir tous les jours pendant les
vacances de 14h à 20h et les mercredis
samedi et dimanchees hors vacances aux
mêmes horaires en complément de Goya qui
prendra fin comme Tintin le 7 janvier 2
[Musique]
et puis Disneyland Paris faête ses 100
ans dans les studios Walt Disney alors
si vous l'avez raté je vous propose de
revenir sur la célébration du 100e
anniversaire de Walt Disney Studio un
événement unique fêté comme il se doit
dans son célèbre parc d'attraction avec
au programme PARAD inédite costume des
cent ans pour le tandem Mickey et mini
et un spectacle nocturne exclusif dans
les parcs francilien des images de
Mélanie fort pour 20 minutes
TV 100ans personnage Disney réunis pour
un siècle de
[Applaudissements]
magie Disneyland Paris rassemble pour la
première fois tous les grands classiques
et la nouvelle génération pour fêter les
100 ans de la Walt Disney compagnie
fondé le 16 octobre
1923 au programme une parade et des
costumes
inédits puis c'est autour des 100 Disney
volonteers d'entrer dans la danse
Disneyland salue l'engagement des 1000
Cast Members bénévoles pour des œuvres
caritatives tout au long de l'année un
spectacle grandieuse pour les fans pour
beaucoup l'univers Disney a changé leur
vie on a vraiment réservé ce jour pour
venir quoi pour les 100 ans du de et
compagn j'ai baigné dedans grâce à mes
parents mon père il a travaillé quelques
années on regard les les disney quand on
était enfant même en grandissant on est
encore dans la magie
pour Disneyland Paris cette date est
historique c'est une vraie aventure
parce que tout comme Walt Disney le
disit
lui-même tout a été commencé par une
souris et aujourd'hui on voit à travers
tous les univers tout les franchise
toutes les histoires qui sont raconté
par the world Disney Company la
célébration d'un siècle qui vient ouvrir
une nouvelle ère pour la franchise on ne
cesse à the worldy company de se
réinventer de trouver de nouellçons de
raconter des histoires part dans le
monde et ici à Disneyland Paris on peut
se tourner dans un futur proche avec la
réouverture du Disneyland Hôtel le 25
janvier prochain la symphonie des
couleurs Disney tout un programme sur le
parc Disneyland à partir du 8 janvier et
plus loin bien sûr l'expansion des Walt
Disney Studios qui va continuer à
prendre de l'empleur le futur est plus
radieux qu' ne l'a jamais
été une belle promesse pour le parc
depuis son ouverture en
1992 300 millions de visiteurs se sont
plongés dans l'univers de Mickey et de
ses
amis voilà et puis avant de nous quitter
je voulais absolument que l'on salue
l'exploit de Frédéric portier amputé de
la jambe gauche après un accident de
scooter il y a 2 ans seulement après un
entraînement intensif ce varoi
accompagné de son équipe médicale et
technique a eu besoin de 6 jours
seulement pour gravir les
5895 m le séparant du sommet du
Kilimanjaro plus haut sommet d'Afrique
par la voie macamé 6 jours c'est le
temps habituel nécessaire au valide pour
ce type d'ascension notre partenaire la
Provence l'a rencontré à son retour
regardez cette interview c'est surtout
la fierté de dire et ben je suis arrivé
en haut et de faire voir à mon fils
Thomas que j'ai pu le faire VO ton père
même avec un handicap il a pu arriver en
haut arrivé à 5895 m d'altitude quand il
restait les les TR les 300 m pour monter
les derniers là là j'en pouvais plus
physiquement et je suis monté avec le
mental voilà le mental je me suis je me
suis mis un coup de mental et de dire
allez il faut monter il faut monter moi
mon objectif c'est d'aller faire les se
sommets et de prouver que même avec une
prothèse on peut faire ces se sommets là
et y arriver en haut et être le premier
mondial à faire ces SEP sommets là voilà
merci d'avoir suivi ce grand JIT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
[Musique]
tous